not really I I definitely wasn't the
sensitive lad hanging off to the side
composing things while the other boys
frolicked I I don't I think I could have
gone to law school or something I knew
that I wasn't going to I think most of
the people my age who were in roughly
journalism whatever that is sort of
backed in I don't think many of us you
have to remember that in though in those
days journalists so-called except for
one or two people in Washington like
walter Lippmann or somebody like that
we're sort of a scruffy lot I mean they
were thought of as this guy with a kind
of greasy suit in a bottle of bourbon in
the lower right hand drawer and and it
wasn't a very respectable profession or
trade or whatever it is and I think most
of the people my age who ended up in it
sort of backed in I wrote about this not
long ago when i wrote a piece about
Johnny Apple RW Apple jr. of the New
York Times I wrote a profile of him in
New Yorker we had met in college we were
caught him he was the editor of the
paper at Princeton the year I was the
editor and Yale and he always knew he
wanted to work for the New York Times
since the age of about twelve I think
it's really rare from people my age I
think most of us couldn't make up our
minds about what to do and happen to be
working at a magazine or a paper when we
realized we couldn't make up our minds
or we sort of backed into it or the
novel didn't work out or or something
but I don't I don't think there are many
people I didn't think of it exactly as
being a writer I think I thought of
bigger reported well for one thing
people go into it on purpose I think
water Watergate had a lot to do with
that or maybe the movie and I suppose it
did on I think more educated people are
going have gone into journalism maybe
not in the past couple of decades from
the past probably three or four decades
I remember once when a friend of mine
who is now on the new york times it was
then working for another paper in
Washington who had gone to boarding
school and gone to Yale and gone gotten
a master's at Berkeley or in history or
something he was talking about coming
back from a hearing and trying to find
somebody secretary so so she could lie
to him about whether the guy was in and
then and then he was going to have to
call somebody else and he looked around
the newsroom of the paper and he saw
other guys doing the same sort of thing
and he said I started to think it is
this a job for a college graduate and
and the answer always was no really
until recent decades not not as recent
as two but recent decades yeah the
answer was really no and so I I think
more people with education and
intelligence and language ability and
that sort of thing have gone into
journalism compared to the people who I
mean I don't mean that then when I went
to the New Yorker was a bunch of Yahoo's
I mean they were fairly sophisticated
people but in general particularly
papers out in the country it wasn't true
and I think I think people also have
different expectations of it I mean
some some reporters have gotten rich
nobody ever thought there'd be a rich
reporter and I mean not from journalism
usually but certainly the ones on
television have gotten rich from from
journalism and a lot of it's become more
bottom line show business particularly
of course television which is I mean
when you think about the arguments about
or the analysis of who's the anchor on
on a on a show and I don't blame those
people most of them are good people who
have worked hard to get there but when
you think about say their salaries and
what the set costs or what the
improvements to the set costs and then
the remodeling of the improvements and
you're talking about an organization
that has closed bureaus all over the
world so it's getting and the same is
true with newspapers although they don't
have the anchor people on but the so in
some ways it's journalism has more
educated people in it and is also
shrinking and one of the ways that's
changed is that if you go to
Philadelphia or you go to Baltimore and
you look at how many reporters are
covering the city government there i
don't know i recently read i think it
was in Philadelphia something like a
quarter of what they're used to be so so
it it's in some ways it's not doing his
job well I think I you know it's
interesting I read something the other
day that has made a very interesting
point i think it was in conjunction with
the debate that was on youtube where
citizens civilians as we would call them
ask questions as opposed to reporters
and the debate just as silly as the
other debates of knowing people's not
only debate
sort of nonsense soundbite thing but the
interesting thing is not the answers but
the questions on reporters tend to ask
questions about how the campaign's going
or how something is going to play
compared to something else the reporters
are generally interested in the process
and that's what's so stupid about saying
oh you know eighty percent of them vote
Democratic something they don't in the
first place they're not ideal logs that
that's just how they vote but they but
also they're much more interested in the
game than they are in in the ideology
and and reporters in general are are
interested in politics and bored by
government so that's why the minute the
election is over they start talking
about the next election and that's why
when you think about it about eighty
percent I'm just made up that figure of
the coverage of an American election is
about who's going to win something we're
all going to know on election night even
if the reporters were all death rate
we're still going to know if they're
going to count the votes and we're going
to know who won so why do they keep
telling us who's going to win or lose
it's not really the point rather than
tell us what that guy really believes or
what he's likely to do the other thing
reporters ought to try to do is is and I
you know I don't mean that they don't do
some of this but the actual issues of a
campaign aren't usually the issues that
the president deals with I mean if you
voted on the issues you would have voted
for what's discussed in the campaign you
would have voted in the Kennedy Nixon
election according to what your beliefs
were on the future of the islands of
chemo and Matsu that became a big issue
between kennedy and nixon
would we go to war to protect key Moya
matsu two islands off taiwan that were
sometimes shelled by the mainland
communist china um that's not the
difference between kennedy and nixon and
that's not course once the election was
over that was the end of chemo amat suit
nobody's heard of chemo omatsu since so
i think that that that that somehow
election coverage should should really
tell us kind of person is that because
the decisions he's going to make or not
the decisions that are talked about
during the campaign there there other
there other decisions
you